[تصفيق]
مره اخرى ومن دون سابق انذار ارتفع سعر
صرف الدولار امام الدينار في السوق
السوداء ما تسبب في اضطراب الحركه
التجاريه في العراق ورفع معه اسعار المواد
الاستهلاكيه بشكل جنوني
راتب مجرد ما يجي الراتب تروح للسوق السعر
مرتفع يعني ماكو اي سوق عندنا يعني هذا
صرف الدولار يؤثر على المواطن طبعا
هذا الامر اثار العديده من التساؤلات لدى
العراقيين هنا عن اسباب ارتفاع سعر الصرف
الذي اثقل كاهلهم وزاد من ابائهم
وزير الخزانه الامريكيه لشؤون الارهابي
والجرائم الماليه الى بغداد بعد رصدها
عمليات تهريب واسعه للدولار خارج العراق
من قبل
محليه استبعدها البنك المركزيه من مزاد
بيع العمله الصعبه
مبيعات البنك المركزي من الدوله الى اكثر
من 40% ما ادى الى زياده الطلب عليه في
السوق السوداء
الامريكي لمتابعه اين يذهب
بالاخص مع الاربعه مصاري
لعبه دورا ايضا خارجيه وداخليه
والطفيليين يستغلون
والاحتكار
ويمارسون ضغوط على السوق المحليه
الى تاسيس منصه الكترونيه جديده لبيع
الدولار والحوالات الخارجيه معتبرا ان بعض
المصاريف ليس لديها الاستعداد الكافي
لتلبيه الشروط الجديده لكنه لم يشر الى
تمكني الخزانه الامريكيه من تتبع المصارف
التسعه المتورطه باخراج الدولار من العراق
الى كل من تركيا وايران وسوريا ولبنان دون
استثماره في سلاح او خدمات داخل البلاد من
بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه